well let me begin by uh
saying on from all three of us
the vice president the new secretary of
homeland security
that our hearts go out to the families
of fbi special agents
and two of whom were killed three of
whom were
were injured today in florida i was
briefing this tragedy earlier today and
i know the fbi is gathering information
about
how this happened what happened but
i i can only imagine
how these families are feeling today you
know one of the things when you are
in a combat zone as a military or your
fbi agent or military or a police
officer
every family just when they put that
shield on and go out in the morning
dreads the possibility of a
call receiving that phone call and uh
my heart aches for the families i've not
had an opportunity nor will i try today
to um to contact them but
they put their lives on the line and uh
it's a hell of a price to take
and every single day every zionist host
get up for the uh
by and large the vast vast majority of
these men and women
our decent honorable people put
themselves in the line
we owe them but the purpose
of my asking you here today is i want to
congratulate
the new secretary secretary marcus i'm
going to
take on an easy job nothing to it
homeland security
and and uh going to deal looking forward
to his leadership and working with
congress
on a lot of issues including the
immigration bill that has
i think great support in both chambers
today i'm going to sign
a few executive orders
to strengthen immigration system
building on
the executive actions i took on day one
to protect dreamers
and to end the muslim ban and to better
manage our borders
and that's what these three different
executive orders are about i want to
make it clear there's a lot of talk
with good reason about the number of
executive orders that i have signed
i'm not making new law i'm eliminating
bad policy
what i'm doing is taking on the issues
that
99 of them that the president the last
president united states
issued executive orders i thought were
very counterproductive to our security
counterproductive to who we are as a
country
particularly in uh in
the area of immigration this about how
america is safer stronger more
prosperous when we have a fair
orderly and humane legal immigration
system
and with the first action today
we're going to work to do the moral and
national shame
of the previous administration that
literally not figuratively ripped
children from the arms of their families
their mothers and fathers at the border
and with no plan none whatsoever to
reunify the children who are still
in custody and their parents
the second action addresses the root
causes of our migration
to our southern border and the third
action
the third order i'm going to be signed
orders a full review
of the previous administration's harmful
and counterproductive immigration
policies basically across the board
and so with that i'm going to sign the
first order
which is a re-establishment of the
interagency task force and a
reunification of
families
remove the stain on the reputation for
what the separation has caused
that is the first order
the second order i'm signing is creating
a
comprehensive regional framework to
address the causes of migration
and to manage migration throughout the
north and central america
and to provide safe and orderly
processing of asylum seekers
at the united states border
and third order i'm signing
is restoring the faith in our legal
immigration system
and strengthening immigration and
inclusion efforts
for new americans
my grandfather say the grace of god and
good will the neighbors will
reunite these children and re-establish
our reputation as being a haven for
people in need
thank you very very much